حسنًا ، الولايات المتحدة في حربها ضد
التدخين تخطط الآن لفعل ذلك ،
فقد طلبت دولة واحدة فقط في العالم
من شركات التبغ خفض
كمية النيكوتين في السجائر التقليدية ،
فلماذا نأمل أن
تجعلهم أقل إدمانًا
للمدير السابق  قال مركز التبغ التابع لإدارة الغذاء والدواء
لصحيفة نيويورك تايمز إن اقتباس هذه
القاعدة الواحدة يمكن أن يكون له أكبر تأثير
على الصحة العامة في تاريخ
الصحة العامة ،
ضع في اعتبارك هنا أن التدخين لا يزال
يقتل ما يقرب من نصف مليون
شخص سنويًا حوالي 1300 شخص يوميًا
وفقًا لـ  جاكلين هوارد من مركز السيطرة على الأمراض والوقاية منها CNN
ينضم إلينا ويعيش الآن من أتلانتا ،
لذا سيقطعون النيكوتين ،
وستظل السجائر موجودة ،
وهذا صحيح ، هذا لتقليل
النيكوتين على أمل مساعدة الناس على الإقلاع عن
التدخين وتقليل عدد
المدخنين المنتظمين الموجودين هناك.  لكن هذا
لن يحدث لبعض الوقت ، لذا فإن ما
يمكن أن نتوقعه بعد ذلك سيتعين على إدارة الغذاء والدواء
إصدار إشعار بوضع القواعد المقترحة
من قبل إم.  ay 2023 وبعد ذلك
سيكون هناك بعض الوقت
للتعليق العام وتذكر أن شركات التبغ يمكن أن تقاضي
حتى لا تحدث هذه القاعدة ،
لذا كل ما علينا أن نضعه في الاعتبار
يمكن أن يضيف إلى الجدول الزمني حتى نتمكن من
رؤية هذه القاعدة الفعلية  في مكانه ولكن
فيما يتعلق بجوانب الصحة العامة هنا ، إليك
كيفية استجابة مجموعات الصحة العامة
لهذا ، تقول جمعية السرطان الأمريكية
إنها تدعم بقوة
نية الإدارة لتعيين
مستويات قصوى من النيكوتين في السجائر
لتقليل إدمانها ، ثم
سمعنا أيضًا  من حملة
الأطفال الخالية من التبغ وتلك المجموعة تقول
اقتباسًا أن هذا اقتراح يغير قواعد اللعبة حقًا ،
لكن هذه المكاسب لن تتحقق إلا
إذا أظهرت الإدارة وإدارة
الغذاء والدواء (FDA) التزامًا تامًا
بوضع اللمسات الأخيرة على
الاقتباس النهائي لهذا الاقتراح وتنفيذه.
انظر إيريكا لا يزال هناك الكثير من
الوقت الذي يتعين علينا رؤيته
حتى يؤتي ثماره